nach einschätzungen der nasa ist er
einer der gefährlichsten hast du ihnen
überhaupt nur hat einen durchmesser von
500 metern und ein stattliches gewicht
von 87 millionen tonnen einen aufprall
auf der erde hätte fatale folgen würde
nach berechnungen der nasa wohl eine
energie von 80.000 atombomben freisetzen
und bleiben noch 100 jahre um
gegenmaßnahmen für diesen möglichen
asteroideneinschlag zu erarbeiten und
damit beginnen wir genau jetzt an
silvester am 31 12 2018 zehn beginnt die
sonde osiris rex mit der annäherung auf
5 kilometer und beginnt dann mit der
näheren untersuchung von wenn du kriegst
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
am 25 september 2001 135 könnte pendelt
der erde tatsächlich gefährlich nahe
kommen und bleiben also noch 100 jahre
um gegenmaßnahmen für diesen möglichen
asteroideneinschlag zu erarbeiten
und genau daran tüftelt die behörde
namens planetary die fans team der nasa
bereits mit hochdruck stichwort hemmer
das steht für high velocity street
migration mission for emergency response
wege ein neun meter langes und knapp
neun tonnen schwere raumschiff das mit
einer delta 4 heavy in den weltraum
gebracht werden soll es könnte nicht nur
als transportmittel für eine atombombe
dienen sondern auch als rammbock
beispielsweise eben für benno denn ein
kleiner schubser könnte den hast du ihn
zu einer kursänderung bringen und selbst
wenn dieser erst einmal nur minimal wäre
könnte dieser schubst den kurs mit einer
gewissen vorlaufzeit im laufe der zeit
immer weiter verschieben
doch erst einmal müsste das raumschiff
gebaut werden die mission und die
flugzeit geplant werden und je mehr zeit
vergeht desto schwieriger gestaltet sich
dieser plan zehn jahre vor dem
errechneten einschlag von benno bräuchte
man schon bis zu 53 solcher hemmers um
seinen kurs zu ändern oder aber man geht
doch mit einer atombombe geben wobei es
hierbei auch wieder einige risiken gibt
wenden könnte in mehrere teile
aufgespalten werden die dann weiterhin
kurs auf die erde nimmt so oder so
musste es so ist jetzt erstmal genauer
untersucht werden
denn davon hängt ab wie und was gegen
bern
eingesetzt wird die sonde osiris rex
wird den hast du ihn jetzt erst einmal
mit fünf instrumenten und kameras
genauer unter die lupe nehmen
2020 wird sich die sonne dann noch
weiter nähern und tatsächlich proben von
benno nehmt das geschieht folgendermaßen
dazu wird von der sonde aus stickstoff
auf den asteroiden geblasen also sie
landet gar nicht und so materie von ihm
gelöst und ein proben sammler an bord
der sonde soll dann 60 bis 2000 gramm
davon einsaugen und zurück zur erde
bringen im september 2000 23 ist dann
die landung auf der erde vorgesehen
neben erkenntnissen über asteroiden art
rohstoffquellen und grundlagenforschung
soll dann vor allem geklärt werden aus
was benno besteht und wie er von einem
kollisionskurs mit der erde abgebracht
werden kann ist er ein massiver
felsblock dann muss ja ganz anders
attackiert werden als wenn er nur aus
losem geröll besteht beides ist möglich
2023 wissen wir mehr und er erfand das
natürlich hier und zwar zuerst nur wenn
er unseren whatsapp newsletter bestellt
das geht hier einfach draufklicken dann
bekommt ihr die videos vor allen anderen
als wozzeck nachricht und darunter geht
es weiter mit die erde entgegen knapp
einem großen asteroiden einschlag
tja ansonsten also unbedingt darauf
gegen interessantes spannendes video
ansonsten bis dann bleibt